[Musica]
mentre si mangia è di tufo in prima pagina è
fiducioso h aperto sì bene questo giovane
turista al mito o alla stanza del flo
[Musica]
e inchallah
Il ministro tedesco Heynckes ha detto che era eti
flusso dell'acqua troverà il supporto
vediamo nei sistemi 3d che noi
alla fine sarà il biglietto per dirlo - chi può
aver lasciato che questo fuoco sfuggesse l'aspetto
talento totale
con cipolle
[Musica]
fabre dikalo oignies
ciò che era necessario
perse
lei non si attiene a questo, ha detto perché noi
non riesco a trovare
è su una macchina
forse limitato
non è così tanto
voi
il diabete affrontarlo
Mettere in
questo volo di annegamento di allier
è ora di concludere la mia fabre night
è suo fa la mia apparizione in ritardo
tutto rimosso
baci
[Musica]
il padre ha poi fabbricato perché nessuno dei due
Deve essere fatto
perse
rené ricol ha detto cosa succede se diciamo ragazzi
timida regressione soffre di una cervice
saleh come uno dei mesi in cui si trova
produttore è un traghetto condizione che
sono serate da favola
[Applausi]
tissot
e
noi
[Musica]
Sono la staffetta di persone che hanno questo senso
sono una bevanda alcolica
Lo farò burro e bellezza
di casa sono il mio miglior bisonte
i giochi zoppicano la sofferenza e non mi interessa
pazzo per le conseguenze
ecco perché lo faccio e anche se
fa male e ho finito tutti i salti
la corsica non è per le risate come la mela
quelli per quello che soffrono tranne me
Bevo bevo volte
[Musica]
uscita
quello che vedo
vita ma anche
anche su di te
[Musica]
Oh
Ho lasciato questi sono
i miei figli sono l'uomo larrazet che
cover movie alcol life you c is
triste è per questo che penso di
trovato al museo si è fermato a spiegarsi
tutti al ponte stasera I
credete però alla tristezza e se il
la depressione è
sai che mi salvo questo mio corpo io
seguirà il condimento sarà peggio
risvegliato con l'avvento
il mio nome è segno sono qui e
io, penso
[Musica]
voi
vita
anche cura
[Musica]
a
pensiamo che tutti non bravi stavo leggendo
stupore bambini piccoli
questo è il mio obiettivo questa è la mia canzone questa è
per tutti voi
genitori ti ho proprio come lei
moglie si uccide
[Musica]
Ho visto un ginocchio più bello che bevo il tuo
cantiere vedo credere quello che ho visto
l'audi tutte le mie preoccupazioni stessa canzone tu
[Musica]
mi sono sentito
vedrai
avi
ma questi
come il suo
m
a
radice
[Applausi]
[Musica]
bandire
in
ti ho fatto piangere tutti i giorni i
piattino per il suo dolore e Tony che volevo
torna alla memoria seguito dal vedere tutto
anche soffrire il divario sembra ahimè
perché non potevo dirlo a me stesso
potresti chiedere la scatola tu me
dire che non è caduto sentito
è solo un gioco a scelta
cosa devo superare i tempi
dal momento che koleos hollow lo sento
nome non più macchine mettilo lì
termina la voce ma yahvé non rovinare vedermi
Riduco i maiali
[Musica]
beneteau
Non sono fedele ferito
Lo sapevi che ho tradito tutto ciò che abbiamo
avere quelle promesse promesse
[Musica]
[Applausi]
Spero
[Musica]
di solito ho rotto due campi
per avere i capelli guardami lo sono
come ferite e sentirlo
Ho avuto non li ho tutti
Voglio che i giornali scoppino quando
Voglio vederti soffrire scegli
anche sulle foglie perché I
non è successo quando hai pianto nel
braccio mentre non ti senti
solido perché non sono spesso così
costedoat questo è il mio defunto dovuto
So anche che lo sento da un nome
[Musica]
Ottengo qualcosa che tutti noi viviamo
vieni eto'o
Non sono fedele
m
sulla scena
io molto velocemente
m
e
carney
a
m
[Musica]
dove
Non voglio dirti che non potrei
per dirti
[Musica]
[Applausi]